The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's get started.
Can you go ahead and take 10
more seconds on this first
clicker question here?
OK.
So it looks like most of you
got that the electron
configuration that we're writing
here is for copper.
So I'm actually going to give
the benefit of the doubt that
the people that didn't get it
right were rushing to get out
their clickers and didn't
have time to think
it all the way through.
Remember that when we're talking
about 4 s 1, 3 d 10,
that's one of those exceptions
where a completely filled d
orbital is more stable
than we would expect.
So, that's actually the electron
configuration we have
when we're talking about
copper and some other
exceptions in the periodic table
that you're going to be
looking at.
So, hopefully, if you were to go
back and look you could see
that this is, in fact, copper.
We're actually going to do one
more clicker question to get
started with today, and as we
do, I'll explain something
we're going to be trying today,
which is a little bit
of a friendly competition in
terms of answering the clicker
questions correctly.
So we've tagged each of your
numbers to your actual
recitation, so we can see
today which recitation
actually is going to be doing
the best in terms of clicker
questions, who's going to get
the most correct today.
So, you may or may not know this
about your TAs, but this
is a pretty competitive group of
TAs we have this year, and
they like to brag about how
smart their recitation is, how
good questions they're getting
in the recitation section.
So, do your TA proud today and
see if you can be part of the
recitation that gets the most
correct in terms of a
percentage.
And at the end of class we'll
announce which recitation that
is, we'll also make sure to
give you a little bit of a
prize if you are, in fact,
in that recitation.
So we have extra incentive
to get these
clicker questions right.
So, in this one we're selecting
the correct
electronic configuration
for an ion.
So, why don't you go ahead and
take 10 more seconds on this
second clicker question
for our intro.
OK.
So, it looks like we have
a little bit of a mixed
consensus here.
Let's go over this question.
And I know there's a lot to
talk about about this
competition, but let's just get
into listening mode here
and talk about how we can figure
out what the correct
electron configuration
is for this ion.
Remember, ions are a little
bit different.
The first thing we need to
do is write the electron
configuration for the atom
itself, and then we need to
take an electron away.
So here we're talking about v
plus 1, so if we were to write
it just for the neutral electron
itself, we would find
that the electron configuration
is argon, that's
the filled shell
in front of it.
Then 4 s 2 and 3 d 3.
So this would be for the actual
filled, the completely
neutral atom.
But remember what we said,
which was when we talked
about, this is at the end of
class on Friday, we said that
it turns out that even though
3 d is higher in energy when
it's not filled, once we fill
it with an electron, these 2
orbitals actually switch place
in terms of energy.
So if we were to write this in
terms of energy, we would
actually have to rewrite it
has 3 d 3, and then 4 s 2.
So, which orbital would we take
an electron out of if we
were ionizing this atom here?
The s.
So, we would actually take an
electron out of the s, which
gives us 3 d 3 and then 4 s 1.
So, it's a little bit of
a trick when you're
dealing with ions.
The best suggestion is just to
write it out completely for
the neutral atom, and then you
want to take an electron out
of the highest orbital.
It makes sense that it's going
to come out of the highest
occupied atomic orbital, because
that's going to be the
lowest amount of energy
that's required to
actually eject an electron.
All right.
So let's go to today's notes.
And actually before we start
into today's topics, I want to
remind everyone and hopefully
you all do remember that our
first exam is coming up and it's
coming up in exactly a
week, so it'll be a week from
today, next Wednesday.
And on Friday in class, at the
beginning of class, I'll go
over just in all the detail
you could possibly imagine
everything you need to know
logistically for the exam --
where it is, what you do, what
kind of calculators you can
bring, which by the way
are any calculator.
So you'll get all of that
information on Friday.
So don't worry if you have
some questions right now.
I just want to let
you know that.
The other thing I want to let
you know is that instead of
having a new problem-set that
you'll be assigned this
Friday, what we'll do instead
is we'll give you some
practice problems, and these
will be just more of the same
type of problems that you saw
before but that's another
chance to try them out more.
These won't be graded, you don't
have to turn them in,
it's just to give you some extra
practice if you want
while you're studying
for the exam.
We'll also post an exam from
a previous year so you can
actually see exactly what the
format's going to look like.
So when you go into the exam a
week from today, it'll all
look really familiar, you'll be
comfortable with the format
and you can just dive
right in and start
answering the questions.
So you'll have all that
information and we'll get it
to you on Friday.
The other quick thing I want
to say is that I do have
office hours today from 3 to 5,
so feel free to stop by if
you have questions about
problem-set 3 that you're
finishing up.
And also, for those of you that
did sign up for the pizza
forum tonight, that's going to
be at 5 o'clock, it's in room
56-502, so we'll see some of you
tonight for that as well.
All right.
So, let's move on to what we're
talking about today.
What we're going to start with
is discussing photoelectron
spectroscopy, which is a
spectroscopy technique that
will give us some information
about energy levels in
multielectron atoms. We'll then
take a turn to talking
about the periodic table,
we'll look at a bunch of
periodic trends, including
ionization energy, electron
affinity, electronegativity
and atomic radius.
And then, if we have time at the
end, we'll introduce one
last topic, which is
isoelectronic atoms and ions.
I also want to note that the end
of the material today, so
this last topic here, that's the
end of the material that's
going to be on this
first exam.
So whether we finish it today,
or more likely when we finish
it up on Friday, once we get
passed isoelectronic atoms,
that's it, that's all you need
to study for this first exam.
So from that point on it'll be
exam 2 material, so depending
on how you like to come
compartmentalize your
information, you can separate
that in your brain in terms of
what you're trying to learn
right now versus what you can
put off until a little
bit later.
So, let's start with talking
about photoelectron
spectroscopy.
This actually relates very
closely to what we discussed
in class on Friday before the
long weekend, and what we were
talking about is the energy
levels of multielectron atoms.
So what we'll start with today
is talking about the technique
that's primarily used to
actually experimentally figure
out what these different
energy levels are.
And this is called photoelectron
spectroscopy,
and essentially what it is is
very similar conceptually to
what we were talking about way
back in the first couple
lectures when we were
talking about the
photoelectric effect.
Because here what we have is
some atom that we're studying,
in the case, it's going to be
a gas, and we hit it with a
photon that has some
incident energy.
So e sub i, some energy that the
photon comes in with, and
if it has sufficient energy to
eject an electron, it will do
that, and our electron will be
ejected with a certain kinetic
energy, which is going to be
whatever energy is left over
from the initial energy we put
in minus what was taken up in
order to actually ionize
or eject the electron.
So, you can see how this can
directly give us different
ionization energies for
any atom that we're
interested in studying.
For example, with neon we can
think about all of the
different orbital energies
we could be looking at.
In the first case, so
here is the electron
configuration of neon.
So we can think about what
is our most loosely-bound
electron, what's that highest
energy orbital, and it's going
to be the 2 p orbital,
that's going to be
what's highest in energy.
So if we're going to eject an
electron using a minimum
amount of energy, that's where
it's going to come from.
So, you can imagine, that we'll
actually probably have a
lot of kinetic energy left over
if we put a lot of energy
in in the first place.
We're only using up a little
bit to eject the electron,
then we'll have a
lot left over.
So, one difference between
photoelectron spectroscopy
and, for example, the
photoelectric effect is that
in this case, we're not just
looking at one energy level,
which is what we were looking
at from the surface of a
metal, now we're talking about
this gaseous atom.
So we can actually pop an
electron or eject an electron
from any single orbital that is
occupied within the atom.
So, for example, it's not just
the 2 p that we could actually
take an electron from, we
could also think about
ejecting an electron from
the 2 s orbital.
Now this, of course, is going to
take more energy because a
2 s is lower, it has has a more
negative binding energy
than the 2 p, but that's OK as
long as we put in enough
energy, but what we're going to
find is the kinetic energy
coming out with the electron
is actually going to be a
little bit less, right, because
we had to use up more
energy to eject the electron,
so we don't have
as much left over.
There's actually one more
orbital that we could talk
about if we're talking about
this sample case of neon,
which is a 1 s orbital, and if
we're talking about a 1 s
orbital, now we're going to be
even lower in energy still, so
that means the minimum energy
required to eject an electron
is going to be at its highest,
so that means the energy that
we have left over that turns
into kinetic energy for the
electron, is now going to
be really quite small.
And what happens when you
irradiate one of these atoms
that you're studying with this
light is in photoelectron
spectroscopy, you want to make
sure that you put in enough
energy to actually ionize any
single electron that you have
in the atom.
So the way that we really make
sure this is done is that we
use x-rays.
So you know that x-rays are
higher frequency than UV
light, for example, that means
it's also higher energy than
UV light, and if you think
back to our photoelectric
effect experiments, do you
remember what type of light we
were usually using for those?
Does anyone remember?
Yeah.
It was UV light that we used.
Well, we can't guarantee with
UV light we'll have enough
energy to eject every single
electron, so that's why when
we use x-rays, they're higher
energy, you can pretty much be
guaranteed we're going
to eject all of
those electrons there.
So I said that this technique
was used to experimentally
determine what the different
binding energies or the
different ionization energies
are for the different states
in a multielectron atom.
Another way to say
states is to talk
about different orbitals.
So we can do this directly as
long as we have certain types
of information.
The first that we need to know
the energy of the photon
that's incident on
our gaseous atom.
The second piece of information
we need to know is
what actually the kinetic
energy is of the ejected
electron, and that's something
we can just measure by
measuring its velocity.
So we can use an equation to
relate the incident energy and
the kinetic energy to the
ionization energy, or the
energy that's required
to eject an electron.
This should all sound incredibly
familiar, like I'm
just repeating myself in terms
of photoelectric effect,
because essentially that's what
I'm doing, and that's one
reason we spent so much time
and did so many problem-set
problems on the photoelectric
effect.
So what we're saying here is
the incident energy, so the
energy coming in, is just equal
to the minimum energy
that's required to a
eject an electron.
When we talked about the
photoelectric effect, that was
called the work function.
In this case, it's called the
ionization energy, plus
whatever kinetic energy we have
left over in the electron.
So if we want to solve for
ionization energy, we can just
rearrange this equation.
Our ionization energy is going
to be equal to the incident
energy coming in, minus
the kinetic
energy of the electron.
So, let's take a look at the
different kinetic energies
that would be observed in a
spectrum for neon where we had
this incident energy here.
And it turns out that the first
kinetic energy that we
would see or the highest kinetic
energy, would be 12 32
electron volts.
So if that's the case doing a
quick little calculation, what
would the ionization energy be
for a 2 p electron in neon?
Yup, 22.
So, basically all we did was
take 12 54, subtract 12 32,
and we got 22 electron volts.
We can do the same thing
for the other
observed kinetic energy.
So, for example, in the second
case, we say that we see 12 06
in terms of the kinetic
energy.
Same sort of subtraction
problem, what do we have for
the ionization energy
of the 2 s electron?
Good, quick math.
All right, so 48
electron volts.
And let's look at the final
kinetic energy that we'd
observe in this spectrum, which
is 384 electron volts,
so what is that third
corresponding ionization energy?
I couldn't quite hear, but I
have a feeling everyone said
870 electron volts.
So, we can actually kind of
visualize what we would see if
we were looking at a
photoelectron spectrum.
And what we would see if we were
graphing, for example,
increasing kinetic energy,
is we would see 1 line
corresponding to each of these
energies of electrons that we
see coming out.
And, of course, each of those
electrons correspond to an
electron coming out of
a particular orbital.
So in the case of 12 32, that is
our highest kinetic energy,
that means it's our lowest
ionization energy -- it's the
smallest amount of energy it
takes to pop an electron out
of that orbital.
So that's why we see the 2 p
here, the 2 s is 12 06, and it
makes sense that what we see
as the greatest ionization
energy, which is also the
smallest kinetic energy is
that 1 s orbital.
Remember, because that 1 s
orbital is all the way down in
terms of if we're thinking about
an energy diagram, we're
all the way down here, so we
have a huge amount of energy
we have to put into the system
in order to eject an electron.
So what I want to point out when
you're kind of looking at
these numbers here, what the
significance is, look at that
huge difference between what
the ionization energies are
for what we call those valence
electrons, those outer shell
electrons, versus the ionization
energy for the 1 s
orbital -- those are core
electrons there.
So we can think about something
I mentioned last
time, which is when we're
thinking about chemistry and
what's really interesting in
terms of chemical reactions,
it's mostly valence electrons
we're talking about, those are
the ones that tend to be
involved in chemical reactions.
It makes a lot of sense when we
look at it energetically,
because if we think about a 1 s
core electron, that's going
to be held really, really
tightly to the nucleus.
We see that we have to put
this huge energy in to
actually get a 1 s electron
ejected, so it makes a lot of
sense that we wouldn't want to
pay that energy cost in a
normal chemical reaction.
And we don't -- we very rarely
would see these core electrons
actually being involved in
any type of a reaction.
All right, so one thing that I
want to point out, which I
said many, many times on Friday,
and this is perhaps
the last time I'll say it, but
one last time is we can think
about why we only see a line for
the 2 p orbital, versus we
don't see separate lines for a
2 p x, a 2 p y, and a 2 p z.
Remember, we need those three
quantum numbers to completely
describe the orbital.
Why do we just see one
for all the p's?
And the reason is that the
energy of the orbitals, depend
on two quantum numbers, and
that's quantum number n, and
quantum number l.
M does not actually have an
effect, in this case, on the
energy of the orbital.
So that's why we're not
seeing separate
lines in this spectrum.
All right.
So let's go ahead and try an
example here in thinking about
photoelectron spectroscopy.
So, let's say we're looking at
an element and we have an
emission spectra, and we know
that it has five distinct
different kinetic energies
in that spectrum.
We might be asked, for example,
to determine what all
of the different elements could
be that would produce a
spectrum that gave us
5 different lines.
So the first thing that we want
to do, if we're thinking
about something like this, is
just to determine exactly what
orbitals are causing the five
different lines that we're
seeing in the spectrum.
So, if we're talking about five
different orbitals and
we're talking about a ground
state atom, we know that we
just need to start
at the bottom and
work our way out up.
So, our first orbital that an
electron must be coming from
is the 1 s.
What comes after that?
2 s.
All right, then what?
2 p.
After that?
3 s.
Next?
3 p, and that's 1, 2, 3, 4 --
that gives us five different
options, five different
orbitals, five different
energies right there.
So, then all we need to do to
determine which elements that
corresponds to is take a look
at our periodic table.
So we want to look at any
element that has a 3 p orbital
filled, but that does not then
go on and have a 4 s, because
if it had the 4 s filled then
we would actually see six
lines in the spectrum.
So that is relevant for all
of these atoms here, so we
actually have several different
possibilities.
It could be aluminum, silicone,
phosphorous, sulfur,
chlorine or argon.
Any one of these different
elements could actually
produce a photoelectron
spectroscopy spectrum that has
five distinct lines.
If I went on and told you what
the different incident light
was, and what the electrons were
ejected with, and then
you could look up the ionization
energy for the
particular different elements,
you should be able to actually
determine exactly which element
it is, but just with
the information given, we can
only narrow it down to these
choices here.
So let's actually let you try
another example of solving a
problem that has to do with
one of the spectrums. So,
let's turn to another clicker
question here.
Remember, your answer holds
great weight in terms of the
state of the TA bragging
for next week.
So, how many distinct, so again,
we're talking about
distinct kinetic energies, would
be displayed if you're
talking about a spectrum for the
element hafnium, and I'll
tell you here that it has a z
of 72, so you don't have to
spend two minutes searching
your periodic table.
The period of table's on the
back page of your notes if you
don't see that there.
All right.
It looks like a lot of you are
done, so let's take 10 more
seconds here.
Part of the challenge is speed,
too, how quickly you
can get these answers in terms
of getting them in on time.
So let's see what we say.
All right.
So I think I can safely say that
most people had the right
idea and were counting quickly,
though I have a
feeling that some people who
wrote 13 might have forgotten
about those 4 f, the
4 f electrons.
So, remember when you're looking
at your periodic
table, don't forget about the
lanthinides, sometimes they
come into play.
So it's actually 14, and the
way that we got that answer
was we just wrote out or just
looked at your period table,
figured out all of the different
orbitals that you
could have in terms of the
principle quantum number, and
then the l quantum number, and
then write them all down -- it
turns out to be 14, so that's
what the answer is.
So, it looks like this is good,
because we'll have some
separation in terms of not
everyone's going to get 100%
in terms of recitations here,
which is what we're going for.
All right.
So let's turn our attention to a
new topic, which is thinking
a little bit about the periodic
table, and also
talking about periodic trends.
And there's a lot we can explain
by talking about what
we see in the periodic table
in terms of what different
trends are in grouping
different elements in
different spots within
the periodic table.
So, here we have a picture of
Dmitri Mendeleev, who is one
of the scientists responsible
for first compiling the
periodic table.
You'll notice I have what's a
very flattering picture of him
up here, and if you haven't done
the reading yet you might
not think this is particularly
flattering, but if you look at
the picture of him in the book,
you'll notice I chose a
very flattering picture of
Dmitri up here, and here he's
pondering putting these
elements together in a
periodic table.
And he actually did this in the
late 1800's, back before
even all of the elements that we
know today were discovered,
really only about 60% or so, 70%
were discovered then that
we now know today.
But still, he was able to put
together a periodic table.
And what he did what he actually
grouped things in
terms of their chemical
properties.
So the way that we like to
think of things now is in
terms of electron
configurations, right, but at
the time that wasn't
really understood.
So, instead, it was amazing he
was able to group things in
terms of the properties
that he saw.
So, for example, if he was
talking about the group one
metals, lithium, sodium,
potassium -- he noticed these
were all very soft reactive
metals, those
were grouped together.
Versus looking at, for example,
helium or neon or
argon, these are all inert
gases, inert meaning
essentially do not react, those
were grouped together in
the periodic table.
So basically, at the time he
was just going on size and
then traits, but what we
actually know today is that we
can also order things in the
periodic table by electron
configuration.
In fact, that is the most
logical way for us
to look at it now.
So, for example, if we're
actually thinking about
electron configuration and we
look at lithium, sodium and
potassium, these all have
one valence electron.
So basically, that means one
electron in an s orbital in
their outer-most most shell.
So that explains why they're so
reactive, they're all very
willing to give up that 1 s
orbital and then drop to a
lower energy level.
In contrast, helium, neon, and
argon all have filled shells.
That also explains why
they're very stable.
They're not going to want to
add on another electron,
because then it'll have to jump
a very large energy level
and start filling in another
shell -- go from n equals 2,
to n equals 3, and n equals
4, and so on.
So it turns out that we can
really know a lot just by
looking at the periodic table.
You will never in this class
have to memorize anything
about the periodic table.
Depending on what kind of
chemistry you go in to, you
might accidentally memorize
parts of the table, which is
fine, but what you really want
to know how to do is know how
to use the periodic table.
But you actually need to keep
a few caveats in mind as you
do this, which is the fact that
trends predict a lot of
chemical properties, but they
can't predict everything in
terms of biological
properties.
And after the periodic table
was developed in the late
1800's, people didn't understand
this quite as well,
they took things a little
more literally.
They thought, for example, if
you could do something with
one element, if you looked at
an element very close to it,
it would be similar enough that
you could maybe replace
it with that.
Today we know, for example, if
you can put one certain kind
of element in your mouth
or eat that, it doesn't
necessarily mean you want to put
the element next to it and
your mouth as well, that
might not be safe.
But this is things we've learned
as the years have gone
past.
So, let's just take a quick
example to show how not
completely you can use these
periodic trends, that there
are limits.
So if we consider lithium,
potassium, and sodium, they're
all together in the same group
on the periodic table, knowing
what we do about biology we
can immediately think of
sodium and potassium, or even
just knowing what you know
about table salt, for example,
that these are two elements
that we find, and particularly
in the ion form in very high
concentrations in our body.
For example, sodium in our blood
plasma is almost to the
point sometimes of 100 millimol
or that's very, very
concentrated.
Similarly, we find it in table
salt, we're taking it in all
the time, the same with
potassium, think of bananas,
were always eating potassium.
Not so with lithium.
I don't think too many
people and here are
probably taking lithium.
It turns out there's actually
no natural function known in
the body for lithium.
So there's nothing naturally
going on unless we were to
introduce it ourselves in our
body that we know of, at
least, that involves lithium.
But this did not stop people,
for example, in the late
1800's, early 1900's, and, in
fact, in 1927 a new soft drink
was put on to the market and
they wanted to make a
lemon-lime soft drink, these
were very popular in the early
1900's, and to get sort of
that lemony flavor, they
decided to use citric acid, so
that's a good idea, that gives
that soury taste.
And they wanted to use a soluble
salt of citric acid,
so they could have
used sodium, they
could have used potassium.
But, you know why not do
something a little special,
little different,
and they decided
instead to use lithium.
So, here we have this soda with
lithium citrate, some of
you might be familiar with this,
soda is called 7-Up.
So, 7-Up no longer has lithium
in it, but from 1927 to 1950
it did, and, in fact, not only
did they not try to hide the
fact that there's lithium in the
soda, this they used as a
really special marketing
technique, they really pointed
out this is something that
stands out about our soda,
this is something special.
There's a lot of good things
about lithium.
I don't know if you can see,
probably not, what's written
on here, so let me point out
to you a few things.
Lithium, slenderizing, that's
great to see in a soda.
Other nice things about lithium
in your soda, it
dispells hangovers, takes
the ouch out of grouch.
That's very nice.
So basically, you get a lot of
benefit supposedly from this
7-Up soda from the
1920's or so.
And this went on and was
unregulated for some time, but
at some point the Food and Drug
Administration did take a
step in, so here's a case where
they did do something
important -- that's not what I
mean at all -- where they did
take the step, they do many
things that are important,
often not quickly enough.
Here's a -- actually here it
did take 25 years, but they
did, they did eventually
step on before we
started drinking 7-Up.
And what they said was, look,
you can't put this in, we're
starting to notice it does
some strange things.
Because it was in the 1950's or
so, maybe the late 1940's,
that people started to discover
lithium, even though
it had no natural function,
it did do
something in our bodies.
Does anyone know what was
lithium's used for?
Yeah, it's an anti-psychotic
drug, so, for example, some
people with bipolar disorder
even today still take it, it
works really well for some
people, for other people it
doesn't work so well.
But anyway, this isn't really
something you want to have in
your soda, so they did take
it out eventually.
Another side effect if you
take too much lithium is
death, so that's no good to have
in sodas either, and it
might not have been as big a
deal back in the 1920's, but
you can imagine with supersizing
today, this might
be a bigger problem.
So anyway, when we talk about
periodic trends, it doesn't
always match up.
This was eventually taken out,
and actually just for your
interest, there was no overlap
between the time when cocaine
was in Coca Cola and lithium
was in 7-Up, so there was a
few years difference between
those two times, but it's
amazing to think about what does
go into processed foods.
And the other thing to point
out, which I don't know if
this is true or not, but does
anyone know -- well that's
part's true, does anyone know
what the atomic mass of
lithium is?
Yes, it's 7.
So, I don't know if this is true
or not, but I wonder if
that's where the actual
name 7-Up came from.
So, even though we don't have
the lithium anymore, we still
keep that atomic number
7 around.
All right.
So that is an anti-example
of using periodic trends.
So let's go to some actual real
examples, which might
come more in handy
for this class.
So it's going to keep in mind
the limitations, so let's
start off with talking about
ionization energy.
Now this is a good place to
start, because we are very
familiar with ionization energy,
we've been talking
about it in a lot of different
forms for quite a while --
it's that minimum energy
required to remove an electron
from an atom.
And specifically, when we talk
about ionization energy, it's
assumed that what we mean
is actually the
first ionization energy.
So, you can imagine, we could
talk about any of the
different electrons, or we could
talk about taking out an
electron and taking out
second electron.
Whenever you hear the term
ionization energy, make sure
you keep in mind that unless
we say otherwise, we're
talking about that first
ionization energy.
And we know what that's equal
to, this is something we've
been over and over, ionization
energy is simply equal to the
negative of the binding
energy.
So negative e, which is sub n l,
because it's a function of
n and l in terms of
quantum numbers.
So, let's think about kind of
differentiating, however,
between first ionization energy
or just ionization
energy, and other types such as
second or third ionization
energy, and let's take boron
as an example here.
So, if we want to think about
what the first ionization
energy is of boron, what you
want to do is write out the
electron configuration, because
then you can think
about where it is that the
electron's coming out of.
The electron's going to come out
of that highest occupied
atomic orbital, that one that's
the highest in energy,
because that's going to be the
at least amount of energy it
needs to eject something.
So what we'll end up with is
boron plus, 1 s 2, 2 s 2, and
what we say is the delta energy
or the change in energy
as the same thing as saying
the energy of the products
minus the energy of our reactant
here, and we just
call that the ionization energy
-- that's how much
energy we have to put into the
system to eject an electron.
And again, this is just the
negative, the binding energy,
when we're talking about
the 2 p orbital.
So, this is first ionization
energy, let's think about
second ionization energy.
So, second ionization energy
simply means you've already
taken one electron out, now how
much energy does it take
for you to take a second
electron out.
So in the case of boron here,
what we're starting with is
the ion, boron 1 s 2, 2 s 2,
and now we're going to pull
one more electron out.
The highest occupied orbital
is now the 2 s orbital, so
we're going to end up with boron
2 plus 1 s 2, 2 s 1,
plus the electron coming
out of there.
And what we say when we talk
about the delta energy is that
this is going to be equal to i
e 2, or the second ionization
energy, or we could say the
negative of the binding energy
of a 2 s electron in b plus. so
it's important to note that
it's not in b, now we're talking
about b plus, because
we've already taken an
electron out here.
So, similarly if we start
talking about our third
ionization energy, this is going
to be going from b plus
2, to 1 s 2, 2 s 1.
Now we're going to pull that
second electron out of the 2
s, so we end up with boron
plus 3, and then the
configuration is just 1 s 2,
plus our extra electron here.
So, what we call this is the
third ionization energy, or
the negative of the binding
energy, again of the 2 s
orbital, but now it's in boron
plus 2 to we're starting with.
So, this raises kind of an
interesting question in terms
of what the difference is
between these two cases, and
we're talking about
numbers of energy.
So let's address this by
considering another example,
which should clarify what the
difference is between these
ionization energies.
So let's think about the energy
required now to remove
a 2 s electron, let's say we're
removing it from boron
plus 1 versus neutral boron.
So, in the case of boron plus
1, what we are starting with
is the ion, so we're starting
with a 2 s electron, and then
we're going to 2 s 1 here.
And what we call the binding
energy is negative 2 s in b
plus -- this is what we
saw on the last slide.
And the second case here looks
a lot more like what we saw
when we were talking about
photoelectron spectroscopy,
because here we want to remove
a 2 s electron, but it's
actually not the highest
occupied orbital, so that's
not the one that would naturally
come out first, but
let's say we're hitting it
with high energy light
sufficient to knock out all the
different electrons, and
one that we end up knocking
out is this 2 s here.
So if we think about what that
delta energy is, we call that
the ionization of the 2 s,
that's different from saying
second ionization energy.
And that's going to be equal
to the negative the binding
energy of 2 s in b,
in neutral boron.
So, my question to you is are
these two energies equal?
No.
All right, good answer.
So, we can think about why is
it that these are not equal.
In both cases we're
taking an electron
out of the 2 s orbital.
And it turns out that if we're
talking about a 2 s orbital in
an ion, that means it doesn't
have as many electrons in it,
so what we're going to see
is less sheilding.
There are fewer electrons around
to shield some of that
nuclear charge.
So what we're going to see is
less sheilding, which means
that it will actually feel
a higher z effective.
So even though they're both 2 s
electrons, in one case it's
going to think its feeling more
pull from the nucleus,
and it, in fact, will be, than
in the other case, and if its
feeling a higher z effective,
then it's actually going to
require more energy to remove
that electron, right, it's
being pulled in closer and more
tightly to the nucleus,
you have to put in more energy
to rip it away from that very
close interaction.
So, that's the difference in
thinking about different types
of ionization energy, so it can
get a little bit confusing
with terminology if you're
just looking at something
quickly, so make sure you look
really carefully about what
we're discussing here.
If you see a problem that asks
you, for example, the third
ionization energy versus taking
a second electron out
of the 2 s in a photoelectron
spectroscopy experiment, those
are two very different things.
So, let's make sure everyone
kind of has this down, let's
do another clicker
question here.
And in this case we're going to
look at silicone, and we'll
say if you can point out to me
which requires the least
amount of energy.
So, which has the smallest
energy that you have to put in
in order to eject
this electron?
Will it be if you take a 3
s electron from neutral
silicone, if you take a 3 p
electron from the neutral
atom, or if you take
a 3 p from the ion?
So this you should be able to
know pretty quickly, so let's
just take 10 seconds here.
All right, great.
So most of you see that, in
fact, the energy that's going
to be the least that we need to
put in is in case 2 here.
Let's compare case 2 and 3,
since this where some people
seem to have gotten confused.
In case 2, we're taking it out
of -- oh, it's kind of hard to
compare case 2 and 3 when
we can't see it anymore.
In case 2, we're taking the 3
p out of the neutral atom,
whereas in case 3, we're taking
it out of the ion.
Remember in the ion, we're going
to have less electrons
around to counteract the
pull from the nucleus.
So we're going to feel a higher
z effective in the case
of the ion compared to
the neutral atom.
If we have a higher z effective,
it's pulled in
tighter, we have to put in more
energy in order to eject
an electron, so it turns out
that that's why case 2 is
actually the lowest energy
that we need to put in.
The z effective is lower, so we
have to put less energy in
to get an ion out.
So, let's take a look at this in
terms of periodic trends --
that's our topic here, we're
talking about periodic trends.
So as we go across the row,
and this is my beautiful
picture of a periodic
table here.
As we go across the row what
happens is that the ionization
energy actually increases, and
we can think about logically
why it is that that's
happening.
As we go across the row, what we
have happening is that the
z or the atomic charge --
I'm not talking about z
effective here, I'm just
talking about z -- the z is
increasing as we go across a
row, that's easy to see.
But we're still in the same
shell, so we still have the
same n value as we go all the
way across a row in the
periodic table.
So, in general what we're going
to see is that what
happens to z effective if we
have z increasing but we're in
the same shell here.
Would it increase or decrease
z effective?
All right.
Kind of mixed thoughts here.
So it turns out that it
increases, and the reason is
because the predominant thing
that's going on here is that z
is increasing.
So the z is increasing, and
what goes along with it is
that the z effective is
increasing, because it turns
out that while we're in the same
n, even though we know
that energy depends on both the
n and the l in terms of
quantum numbers, while we're
in the same n, the distance
from the nucleus, it's
pretty close,
it's not hugely different.
So the factor that predominates
is that we're
actually increasing z.
That's why we see z effective
increase, and that's why we
see ionization energy
increase.
As we go down a column, what
happens is that the ionization
energy decreases.
We can also think about this
in terms of z effective.
This is because even though z,
the atomic number is still
increasing, we are also
getting further
away from the nucleus.
So, remember when we talk about
Coulomb force, what's
holding the nucleus and the
electron together, there's 2
things we need to think about.
The first is this the z
effective, or how much charge
is actually in the nucleus
that's felt, or the I guess we
would say the z, how much the
charge is on the nucleus that
holds it close together.
But the second factor
is how far away we
are from the nucleus.
So, if we're really close to
the nucleus, that's when z
effective is high, but if we
get really far away, then z
effective is going to get low,
because even though we have
the same charge in the
nucleus, the z
effective gets lower.
So this is not even thinking
about the other electron
shielding, just if we think of
the fact, all we need to think
about is that the effect of
going to a further away n
actually dominates as we
go down the table.
We're getting further away from
the nucleus because we're
jumping, for example, from the
n equals 2 to the n equals 3
shell, or from the n equals
3 to the n equals 4 shell.
And when you're switching n's,
you're actually getting quite
a bit farther away.
That's why in the earlier models
of the atom, they're
not horrible to sometimes think
about just each n value
as a little ring around.
It's not complete and it's not
accurate, but it's OK to kind
of think of it in terms of how
far we're getting away from
the nucleus.
So, as we go down a column, we
see ionization energy's going
to decrease.
So, this means we have the
general trends down, so we
should be able to look at actual
atoms in our periodic
table and graph them
and see that they
match up with our trends.
So here we have that graphed
here, we have atomic number z
graphed against ionization
energy, so, let's fill in what
the actual atoms are here, and
we can see in general, yes,
we're following the trend.
For row one, we're increasing,
as we should, across the row.
Let's look at row two also.
Well, we're generally increasing
here, we'll talk
about that more in a minute.
And also in a row three, yeah,
we're generally increasing,
there's some glitches
here, but the
general trend holds true.
Similarly we see as we go down
the table, so as we're going
from one row to the next row,
so, for example, between
helium and lithium, we see a
drop; the same with neon to
sodium, we see a drop here.
So it looks like we're generally
following our trend,
that's a good thing.
But hopefully, you will not be
satisfied to just make a
general statement here when
we do have these glitches.
So you can see, for example, we
have several places where
instead of going up as we go
across the row, we actually go
down in ionization energy
a little bit.
So between b e, and b, between
n and o, magesium and
aluminum, and then phosphorous
and sulfur, what we see here
is that we're kind of going
down, or quite specifically,
we are going down.
So, let's take a look at one of
these rows in more detail
to think about why this might be
happening, and it turns out
the reason that these glitches
occur are because the sub
shell structure predominates
in certain instances, and
that's where these glitches
take place.
So I've sort of just spread out
what we have as the second
row here, graphed against
the ionization energy.
So, let's consider specifically
where these
glitches are taking place.
So, let's look at the first
one between beryllium and
boron here.
And the glitch that doesn't
make sense just through
periodic trends, is that it
turns out that the ionization
energy of boron is actually
less than the ionization
energy up beryllium.
So I put the electron
configurations and actually
drew it on an energy diagram
here, so we can actually think
about why this might
be happening.
So what is this, which element
did I chart here?
Which one is that, the boron
or the beryllium?
I couldn't tell what
you said, sorry.
So, I'm going to assume that
was beryllium, and then it
turns out that if that's
beryllium, the
other one must be boron.
So, we have beryllium in the
first case here, it has four
electrons, that's how we
know it's beryllium,
boron has five electrons.
So, just looking at putting in
the electrons, filling up the
energy diagram here, we should
be able to see a little bit
why this is happening.
And the reason is simply because
the energy that we
gain in terms of moving up in z,
so from going to z equals 4
to z equals 5, is actually
outweighed by the energy it
takes to go into this new
shell, to go into
this new sub shell.
So to jump from the 2 s to the 2
p, takes more energy than we
can actually compensate with
by increasing the pull from
the nucleus.
So, it turns out that in this
case, and any time that we see
we're going from a 2 s to 2 p,
filling in of electrons, we
actually see that little
bit of glitch
in ionization energy.
So it's shown here for the
second row, but it's actually
also going to be true
for the third row.
The same thing when you're going
from filling in the 2 s
to putting that first electron
into the 2 p.
So that explains one of our
glitches here, but we have
another glitch, and that second
glitch comes between
nitrogen and oxygen.
So, these sound more different,
so I think I'll be
able to distinguish.
Which element is shown here?
Yeah, nitrogen.
So, nitrogen is shown
here, we know that
because it has 7 electrons.
In this case, we're
talking about 8
electrons, which is oxygen.
So if we're comparing the
difference between these 2
now, what you'll notice is that
in nitrogen we have all
half-filled 2 p orbitals, and
now, once we move into oxygen,
we actually have to add
1 more electron into
1 of the 2 p orbitals.
There's no more 2 p orbitals to
put it into, so we're going
to actually have to double up.
So now we're putting 2 electrons
into the same p
orbital, that's not a problem,
we can do it, it's not a huge
energy cost to do that.
But actually there is a little
bit of an energy cost into
doubling up into a single
orbital, because, of course,
it takes energy when you
create more electron
repulsion, that's not something
we want to do, but
we have to do it here, and it
turns out that that effect
predominates over, again, the
energy that we gain by
increasing the atomic
number by one.
So, our two glitches we see when
we go from the 2 p, or
from 2 s to start filling the
2 p, and then we also get
another glitch when we've
half-filled the 2 p, and now
we're adding and having
to double up in
one of those p orbitals.
Again, we see the same
effect as we go into
different rows as well.
So let's talk about another
periodic trend, this one is
called electron affinity.
Electron affinity is actually
the ability of an atom, or we
could also talk about an
ion to gain electrons.
So it's the affinity it has for
electrons, it's how much
it likes to get an electron.
We can write out what it is for
any certain atom or ion x,
so it's just x plus an electron
gives us x minus.
We have the minus because we're
adding a negative charge
from the electron.
So, basically any time we have
a really high positive number
of electron affinity, it means
that that atom or ion really
wants to gain another electron,
and it will be very
stable and happy
if it does so.
So let's look at an example
of chlorine here.
So chlorine, if we talk about
it in terms of electron
affinity, we would be writing
that we're actually gaining an
electron here, and getting
the ion, c l minus.
And the change in energy for
this reaction is negative 349
kilojoules per mole.
So if we have a negative change
in energy for any
reaction as it's written, what
that actually means is we're
giving off energy as the
reaction proceeds.
So, in other words, this c l
minus is actually lower in
energy than the reactants
were.
So that's why we're giving
off extra energy.
We saw a similar thing as we
saw electrons move from
different levels.
We can think of it in the same
type of way when we're talking
about actual reactions
happening.
So, if we have energy that's
released, would you say that
the chlorine ion is more
or less stable than
the chlorine atom?
Who thinks it's more stable,
show of hands?
All right, who thinks
it's less stable?
Very good.
So it turns out it is,
in fact, more stable.
It's more stable because you
actually -- this happens
spontaneously, you actually get
energy out of the reaction
as this happens.
And we haven't talked about
reactions at all yet, so you
don't need to worry about the
specifics of that exactly, but
just that if you have this
negative change in energy, you
have a more stable product
than you do reactant.
So, we were talking, however,
about energy in terms of
electron affinity, so we can
actually relate electron
affinity to any reaction by
saying if we have this
reaction written as here where
we're gaining an electron, we
say that electron affinity is
just equal to the negative of
that change in energy.
So, for example, for the
chlorine case, we would say
that the electron affinity for
chlorine is actually positive
349 kilojoules per mole.
That's a very large number,
it's all relative, so you
don't necessarily know it's
large without me telling you
or giving you other ions to
compare to, but chlorine does
have a very large affinity,
meaning it's really likes
getting an electron and becoming
a chlorine ion.
One major difference between
electron affinity and
ionization energy is that when
we talked about ionization
energy, remember ionization
energy
always has to be positive.
We will never have a case where
ionization energy is negative.
Electron affinity, however, can
be either negative or it
can be positive.
So let's look at a
case where it's
actually going to be negative.
So, if we took the case of
nitrogen, if we add an
electron to nitrogen and go to
n minus, we find that the
change in energy is 7
kilojoules per mole.
This means in order to do that
we actually have to put 7
kilojoules per mole
of energy into the
reaction to make it happen.
So this is not going to be a
favorable process, we're going
to find that the electron
affinity is actually a
negative 7 kilojoules per
mole for nitrogen.
So this means nitrogen has low
electron affinity, it doesn't
actually want to gain
an electron.
So, that also tells us that the
n minus ion is less stable
than the neutral atom itself.
So, we can think about trends in
electron affinity just like
we did for ionization energy,
and what we see
is a similar trend.
Electron affinity increases as
we go across a row in the
periodic table, and
it decreases as
we go down a column.
I left out the noble gases here
because they do something
a little bit special, and
actually, I'm going to give
you one last clicker question
today to see if you can tell
me what you think
noble gases do.
To answer this question you
just really want to think
about what does electron
affinity means.
It means how much a certain
atom actually
wants to get an electron.
So do you think noble gases
would have a high positive
electron affinity, a
low positive, or
negative electron affinity?
So, let's take 10
seconds on that.
All right.
Great.
So most of you recognize, if we
switch back to the notes,
that they do have a negative
electron affinity.
This should make sense to you,
because they don't, in fact,
want to gain another electron,
because that would mean that
electron would have to go into a
new value of n, a new shell,
and that's really going
to increase the
energy of the system.
So they'd much rather just stay
the way they are and not
have another electron come on,
and it turns out that halogens
have the highest electron
affinities.